don't go anywhere being in a bald eagle
nest is surreal
this is a wild animal she's being rowdy
it's very capable of hurting you if
you're not careful so you have to take
your time a little rough huh sorry about
that it's an experience that's hard to
describe my name is Jim Campbell Spitler
I'm a forest canopy ecologist and a
wildlife biologist and I'm pretty sure I
have the best job in the world my job is
to climb into the eagle's nest and
capture and work with chicks yeah he's a
monster and the reason why we're doing
this is we're trying to get blood
samples and we can use those blood
samples to look at environmental
contaminants and how they get into the
bald eagles food source and make me
chase you huh don't you come off there
come down it's a challenging species to
work with it's got a really sharp hooked
beak and it's talons are big and
powerful and you don't want to let them
grab ahold of you because they can
really do some damage all right let's go
down this is a wild animal so you never
know what can happen the Channel Islands
are an island chain off the coast of
Southern California do you think I don't
look people off they're a desert island
system you could out there and you can
stand on top of these Bluffs and you can
see the Pacific a whole 360 degree view
of just the most beautiful ocean you can
ever imagine you've got not only bald
eagles you have peregrine falcons that
are nesting on the sea cliffs just tell
me if she's coming in
you've got a host of different seabirds
and it's just a magical place our
research it may look invasive but really
one of our primary concerns is the
safety of these young birds that were
handling so we go to great lengths to
ensure that we don't injure them and
that when we put them back in the nest
they're just is well off as when we
first encountered them likes you the
bald eagles are national birds so it's
quite an honor for me to get to work
with this species quite often I'll just
sit in that nest for a moment and just
take in the view and just think wow you
know it's just an honor to get up there
be able to share that view and that
experience with them just for that
moment in time